- Hey, come on in.
(bouncy keyboard music)
Yes, push and
believe, you got it.
So Sean, I've
read, I have notes.
You started stand-up in New
Jersey, lives in New York?
- I lived in New
York for four years.
- Well how come it
says lives in New York,
it should be a D and not an S.
- Did you guys get
this from my MySpace?
- Where are my writers
getting this information?
When I answered the door
I was assuming that
you were from New York.
- I mean,
is there part of New York
inside of me, absolutely.
- Let's talk some more.
- Okay.
- You have a web series.
- Yeah I had one.
- And when you
pitch a web series
you go to the internet offices?
- Yeah the internet offices,
there's all these companies
that are doing web series.
- So if I wanted
to do a web series
I don't go to the offices
of Safari or Firefox.
- Yeah you do not go
to the Firefox offices.
- Don't go there.
- You don't go to Google.
- Don't go to Google.
- You find these
little, little branches.
- When you said
branch, I looked over,
I see these grapes here,
and they're kind of
a branch of grapes.
I will break this branch.
- Are they fake?
- No these are real.
- You are, you played
college baseball?
Thank you.
- There you go, I'm
gonna feed you grapes.
Sean, I hit you in
the eye, I apologize.
- It's okay.
- Oh great shot,
you got a bonus!
- Let me try again, you got it,
Steven Brody Stevens,
pitcher for Arizona State,
he knows sports.
Yeah!
Yes, push, believe, you got it.
We did it, now follow
up with one for me.
Yes, you got it,
direct message me.
- By the way, the yes,
are you doing a Marv
Albert impression?
- No, this is Marv
Albert, 'yes.'
- Yes.
- From way downtown, yes!
- Me is, yes.
- Yes.
- You got it, it's a build up,
like one of those video games,
you hold the button down, get
the power, yes, release, push.
- Yes.
- You got it, push, believe,
magnets, yoga, enjoy.
- Got it.
- What a great video, like
it, subscribe, click it.
Comedy Central, in it,
Facebook, we got'cha covered.
Twitter, we're there too,
friendship, I know you got that.
Tell everybody.
We're in this together,
it's teamwork.
I scratch your back,
you shave mine.
Boom, laughter, you got it.
Click, subscribe, all that.
I'm gonna click, I'm gonna
believe, and you should too.